so while the rest of us have been
distracted by omicron
a word that is going to be the punchline
of incredibly bitter jokes five years
from now omicron
as that has been taking up all of our
disk space the country has inexorably
been moving closer to what could be an
incredibly destructive war with russia
our media is encouraging that war on
msnbc the lunatics are demanding to know
why joe biden isn't doing more to defend
the territorial integrity of ukraine
we've got to be aggressive
in our defense
of our allies and ukraine despite what
you hear from putin propagandas
propagandists across the world and yes
even here in america despite what you
hear
we have to defend our democratic allies
and it's time for the biden white house
to start speaking more clearly and more
aggressively and telling us how they're
going to stop this invasion from
happening
people that stupid should not have tv
shows and they certainly shouldn't be
weighing in on adult topics like war and
peace but they are
so you have to ask yourself why is this
happening
why are the russians so upset why are we
moving towards some kind of conflict
well there's one reason
over a number of different
administrations the united states
government has pushed ukraine to join
nato the north atlantic treaty
organization
imagine if mexico fell under the direct
military control of china we would see
that as a threat of course there'd be no
reason for that
well that's how russia views nato
control of ukraine and why wouldn't they
we don't get anything out of pushing
ukraine into nato so why are we doing
this
clinton ehrlich is a russia policy
researcher he understands this issue
quite well and we're happy to have him
join us this evening clint thanks so
much for coming on
so is it too simplistic to say the core
dispute here is over ukraine joining
nato
i would say that that's russia's
perspective but here we have people who
are arguing that even if the russians
don't
invade ukraine that we need to invade
and kick the russians out of crimea that
was an op-ed from a senior obama
administration official this week and so
i would say that it's even simpler than
that we're dealing with our war mongers
unserious people whose policy
prescriptions could have deadly serious
consequences well they're deeply
unserious people and they're also people
with a long and publicly available track
record of failure of conflicts that have
diminished the united states materially
over the last 20 years so why do they
get a say in this their failures
they like to portray themselves as cold
warriors but the architect of america's
strategy during the cold war george
cannon warned that nato expansion could
lead us towards war with russia and he's
been vindicated we're now on the
precipice of that kind of conflict and
so it's a great question why is it that
we should listen to these people well i
couldn't agree more i mean if max boot
is still making your foreign policy it's
kind of your fault i would say but i i
and this is a sincere question is there
something i'm missing is there some
compelling american interest that would
be served by having ukraine and nato
no the the deeper irony is that nato
doesn't even want ukraine that it's a
corrupt country it's more of a liability
than it would be a military asset and
the people who are pushing this simply
argue that it needs to happen because
russia shouldn't have a veto over who's
in nato in other words even when it's in
our mutual interest to not have a state
in nato we have to insist that they'll
be added just to spite the russians
look i want to take people seriously all
people even people i disagree with maybe
especially people i disagree with but
this seems nuts is that your assessment
tucker it's not just nuts it's it's
dangerous i mean we're sleepwalking
towards conflict with a country that has
more than 4 000 nuclear weapons the the
russians are talking about potentially
deploying strategic forces to cuba and
venezuela in a repeat of the cuban
missile crisis and so it's just shocking
that people are not more upset about
this because the lives of americans are
being threatened over a situation where
we have no vital strategic national
interest so since 1945 we really only
fought wars against poor disorganized
third world countries north korea
vietnam iraq afghanistan syria do you
think that that's convinced a lot of our
policymakers that it's like easy to
fight wars
i think that it's convinced them of that
and also we haven't had war inside our
country the russians have they
understand the reality of war and what
it's like to lose millions of people in
a conflict and somehow our policymakers
just imagine that war can never reach us
uh and the reality is that you and i are
in danger from this conflict to tucker
the people that we love are in danger uh
and it's just incredibly disturbing that
this is happening
it really is clinton early i really
appreciate your perspective tonight and
your clarity thank you very much
thank you tucker hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else